et dans le monde
karen à 20 ans il est en train de faire
ses études secondaires
un jeune homme comme les autres pas tout
à fait décent pète situation de rêve
test iphone kate se sont importantes
trahi
or quand tu de cette nasse il habite
depuis quelques semaines chez son
meilleur ami dans une petite ville au
nord de stockholm
un fauteuil on a du mal à croire que
jusqu'en juillet dernier
il gisait immobile nourri par une sonde
dans la maison de ses parents
il a passé quatre longues années dans
cet état nous l'avons rencontré à cette
époque ils ne sont pas justes en dormi
ils sont dans un état comateux depuis
deux ans et demi pour l'un et presque
deux ans pour l'autre
quand nous l'avons rencontré pour la
première fois il ya presque deux ans il
était atteint du syndrome de résignation
sa petite soeur de 13 ans maryam
souffrait du même mal
couché côte à côte dans leur chambre
d'enfant leur état semblait sans espoir
agathe c'est que 6ème levano il ne se
souvient absolument pas de m'avoir déjà
rencontré le syndrome de résignation est
une condition qui depuis la fin des
années 90 a frappé des centaines
d'enfants réfugiés presque exclusivement
en suède les enfants semble endormi ne
réagisse à aucune stimulation et doivent
être nourri artificiellement
le phénomène a été plusieurs fois décrit
au cours des 20 dernières années mais il
a été très peu étudiée par les
spécialistes
l'hypothèse qui est généralement accepté
par la majorité des cliniciens des
intervenants qui travaillent avec ses
enfants
c'est que leur état est causée par le
stress et les traumatismes qu'ils ont
subi mais alors on devrait avoir des cas
semblables ailleurs dans le monde
or le syndrome de résignation est à peu
près inexistants ailleurs qu'en suède
neuropédiatre karl salines qui est en
train de faire des recherches sur le
sujet n'exclut aucune explication tout
le monde admet qu'il y à certains cas de
manipulation il y a quelques semaines ce
magazine suédois a publié un article
relançant une vieille polémique
ces deux ados ont confié aux
journalistes avoir simulé le syndrome
sous la pression de leurs parents
désespérés d'obtenir le permis de
résidence
ce sont deux cas sur plus de 1000
recensés en suède mais je n'ai aucune
raison de croire que ce sont tous des
cas de manipulation
il y à un élément qui contredit les
accusations de manipulation
c'est le fait que ces enfants une fois
le permis de résidence obtenu par la
famille prennent beaucoup de temps à
récupérer jusqu'à cinq mois si on se fie
aux cas étudiés after work ap
grings en juillet dernier car elle n'a
obtenu qu'un permis de résidence
temporaire de 13 mois
suffisant pour qu'en quelques jours ils
ouvrent les yeux et commence à parler un
mois et demi plus tard il commençait à
marcher sans aucun souvenir des années
passées au lit il regarde maintenant
vers l'avenir il va vraiment bien je ne
connais pas d'autre qui soit revenu à la
normale comme karen il a des émotions et
il est capable d'en parler dr suivi plus
de 60 enfants atteints du syndrome de
résignation 15 le sont toujours
mais la plupart se sont réveillés après
avoir obtenu un permis de résidence il
retourne à la vie normale mais les
parents disent en général que leur
personnalité a changé qu'ils sont
devenus plus renfermé plus hésitants
après la maladie
c'est le cas de mariam la petite soeur
de karen elle avait 12 ans quand elle
s'est endormie pour se réveiller deux
ans et demi plus tard toute la famille
en est encore traumatisé un an après
avoir obtenu le permis de résidence
elle s'est réveillée elle a ouvert les
yeux et après elle a commencé à manger
elle n'a commencé à marcher que deux
mois plus tard et elle ne veut pas
parler de ses années passées au lit ni
de sa vie aujourd'hui hélas du mal à
socialiser
il n'y a que le basketball qui fait
apparaître le sourire sur son visage
mais marianne tout comme son frère va à
l'école
tout comme lui elle rêve de devenir
médecin nous allons apprendre la langue
nous allons vivre normalement être utile
au pays
travailler payer les impôts malfaiteurs
goodbye my favorite things heures
contrairement au reste de sa famille
karen est toujours menacée d'expulsion
on nous prochain berlin après cette date
qu'ils fermaient
[Musique]